[Music]
you may have mixed feelings about my
Logan Oppel as many people do but if
you're on the left
you really hate them you've never hated
anybody for some reason as much as Milo
innopolis and the effect is mildly
innopolis can't even go to a bar without
getting driven out by screaming people
it happened over the weekend he went to
a restaurant in Manhattan but he crowd
associated with the Democratic
socialists of America most of whom seem
like rich kids gathered around him to
chant quote Nazi scum get out how many
of those Democratic socialists have
their own student loans probably none
that would be my guess
anyway they claim that the Nazi label is
justified because some of Milo's
supporters once made a Nazi salute they
say so it's not clear that Milo saw him
do it
whatever the mob included an editor at
the Nation magazine called Annie shields
and also a Gizmodo writer named Brendan
O'Connor so we contacted O'Connor and
his editor for a comment asked him to
come on the show tonight they sent us
this statement which they repeated on
the phone go F yourselves because their
writers Chadwick Moore is a New York
journalist he is with Milo at that bar
and he joins us tonight so here's the
amazing thing to me this took place am I
getting any of this wrong this was a
restaurant called Churchill's
named after Winston Churchill it's on
Park Avenue in New York it has $16
salmon appetizers and this was the venue
that the Socialists chose to meet at a
restaurant named after Churchill on Park
Avenue and you notice all of the
nationalistic British flags hanging
around I believe must have come for the
craft beers when I decided you know how
the Socialists love their their $8 craft
beers that's not the only thing I can
come up with surely we thought this
place would be safe we made reservations
we just wanted a simple Sunday roast we
were looking forward to this you know
he's British he has probably has had a
good roast
very long time and we encountered and of
all the gin joints in the world we had
to walk into the one with a socialist
for meeting so they started screaming at
you and calling you names and what
happened well we we had step outside for
a moment and on our way back into our
table they were doing it they were
shouting they would not let us go back
to our table we figured we'd we left our
bags our tables so we're gonna see if
they'd call him down if they didn't we
were just gonna get our bags and leave
out of respect for the staff and and the
other customers other customers you can
see in some of those videos were we're
scared and they were actually running
out with their children so when we tried
to go to the back to our table they
gathered around him and would not let us
go back to our table and then a very
large I think it was a woman it was
looks like a woman ish shoved Milo and
that is when we realized that this was
going to get very violent it was just
the two of us and we asked the staff if
they would please retrieve our bags and
they did very politely and mileages said
I was a very big trump supporter in the
last election and that's what this was
about and the waitress was very confused
and said oh okay clearly none of the
staff or other patrons really knew what
was going on or understood this reaction
we were just two guys trying to have
some lunch trying of a roast or those
Vassar grads are dangerous when they get
mad did you know that they were gonna be
that it was the meeting of the
trustafarians was in progress when you
try this restaurant absolutely not I
didn't even know they knew where Park
Avenue was why their parents do
certainly absolutely not we made
reservations of several days advance we
just wanted an English roast and in this
place had looked and come very highly
recommended that was that was the end of
it I see on Twitter their truck because
the optics of this are so terrible and
they know how awful they look that I see
on Twitter that they're trying to say
that we had planned this I see certified
salon reporters with their blue
checkmarks saying that that Milo had
brought his husband out who everyone
knows that Milo's married to a black guy
I don't know if they think I'm a Sean
Smith Shan King or what but so they keep
trying to say we did this on purpose no
we really wanted to here's one of the
revolutionaries this is Brendan O'Connor
he works at Gizmodo this is the kid we
wanted to have on tonight I don't know
there he is right there and he's
obviously
acting on behalf of the global
proletariat this is the kid who says his
journalist but who was there sort of on
behalf of the Socialists we checked of
needless to say from one of the richest
suburbs of New Jersey went to some fifty
thousand dollar your boarding school
apparently was he one of the people
screaming at you yes he marched outside
and tried to Dorset Milo he shoved a
recorder in his in his face and started
ask him questions about you know
eight-month-old news stories that
involved him and other things that have
been debunked and Milo was just very
polite and had said I'm here with my
friend i if you want if you want to
interview me please you know send an
email to me and we'll set something up
he would not drop it he didn't know what
he was talking about he was clearly
nervous and fumbling and had probably
had no idea what to ask Milo finally
Milo just said leave me alone I'm here
with my friends get your quite get your
facts straight I will have gladly give
you a proper interview that we have of
course this nation editor who admitted
on Twitter she runs the nation's Twitter
handle and she has another worker it's
important to note I don't have to tell
you this but they were all white
obviously out of three shields all three
of them yes yes so she has been going on
a storm on Twitter you know standing up
for the working class and the people and
and you know all of those precious black
you know there was a time when when
social has cared about economics and had
an actual case to make I don't agree
with it but I mean they had a kind of
reason thought-out case yes that was
fundamentally an economic case and then
little rich kids like this got involved
in and it became all about race and
gender like everything is anyway
Chadwick thanks for thanks for joining
us tonight I big [ __ ] we've we've
invited this Brendan O'Connor kid on by
the way and we'll hope he'll come on
from Gizmodo and hopefully oh come on
tomorrow night and explain what he was
doing at Churchill's scene of the
revolution